you know the other thing is like you're
gonna now they're gonna have the
celebrities give the kids graduations be
by the way here's the thing with the
graduation speeches folks there's never
been a time in our society where the
graduation speech is meant less okay
information is everywhere if your kid
wants information they can get it
informations been democratized college
is kind of a scam now like there's
definitely a more cost-effective way to
do college but the idea of like somebody
like what like the people that are
giving these kids like commencement
speeches are like Jimmy Fallon and Ellen
it's like and like the CEOs of companies
it's like guys that's not gonna help you
out right now we're heading towards a
world that's gonna look very differently
you need to have a homeless person give
the commencement speech at the college
so that a lot of these kids are gonna
know what's happening they literally
need a homeless man to get up there with
with with with with like like a Viet
like a Vietnam vet homeless guy to get
up there who's like to shoes but like
they're both got a fallin off and he's
dirty and he's [ __ ] you know he asked
for a cigarette before he starts and you
give him a cigarette and he's like it's
[ __ ] what is this math well where are
we and then he goes into it he tells you
the real [ __ ] you know tells you the
real [ __ ] he goes I went to Vietnam
country doesn't give a [ __ ] I came back
I started [ __ ] this hooker we had a
kid you know who we bought a house she
went insane cuz there's no mental health
care in the country she burned the house
down I ran out with my two children in
the street luckily our neighbor was one
of these Christian freaks she was a real
freak and was kind of annoying but she
took me and my kids in that night my
wife is dead because she
burn the house down because she didn't
get any mental health care and she was
hooking because she was molested by her
father who ironically was in the church
was a deacon not a priest but a deacon
who used to bless his daughter that's
probably why she liked me she liked
fucked-up men that's just the way it is
so we started [ __ ] and she was
fertile I mean she was Porto Rican I
mean [ __ ] fertile they just [ __ ] out
kids these Puerto Ricans and we had two
of these [ __ ] and then she
burnt the [ __ ] house down in the
middle of the night I I was pretty
[ __ ] up I'm not gonna lie I'd been on
a coke bender for like three days I'm
pretty drunk so what happened was I felt
the flames they were touching my feet
nice I woke up and I'm like I hope my
kids aren't burned I hope they're not
burned so I ran into their room and they
were sleeping like angels I mean literal
angels it was the only moment I believed
in God and as soon as I had that
awakening where I believed in God I
thought immediately of the devil because
I saw the flames that's the duality of
man isn't it the duality of life God in
the devil and then I ran outside and my
ass was still kind of hot because the
flames caught onto my jeans and I was
always like breathing fire because I was
drinking whiskey that night trying to
get to sleep there - the coke bender so
I'm in the middle of the street
half-naked with these two kids their
mother is being burned to death in the
house the fire department didn't come
because we live in the [ __ ] Bronx so
they waited for the [ __ ] whole house
to go up so then finally my [ __ ]
freak Christian neighbor comes out took
my kids in got them closed those kids
went into foster care went to the state
they found me later told me I [ __ ] up
their whole life one of them's in jail
the other one's somewhere out on the
[ __ ] street man I had a security
coward job for like half a year in 96 I
don't really know what's been happening
since anyway so I just want to say to
the class of 2020 that you know just
onward and upward brighter things are
ahead and you know a lot of people and
these things my saying the most
important lesson I've learned and the
most important lesson I've learned in my
life is kind of did you just say [ __ ]
you know and then he would light a
cigarette and then he leaves the digital
graduation and then that's really that's
a grand
just stunned stunned soulless
tick-tock youth in their [ __ ] rooms
with their parents their [ __ ] parents
[ __ ] in their mouths again
some of them giggling some of them
floored staring at each other being like
what the [ __ ] just happened that would
be so much of a more valuable
commencement speech than some [ __ ]
celebrity who's there to talk about how
you just have to keep going and then
eventually Lauren Michaels will see
enough with that [ __ ] tell them what it
really is tell them what they've won
Bill Gates does a speech he goes there's
a needle under everyone's chair it's
already pricked you in the ass and we're
gonna see how now you walk we're gonna
see here during my speech we're gonna
study your reactions and see what
happened